we're just dying to see heavyweight
boxing have a tremendous long
Renaissance and obviously these two guys
have been leading it and a guy who would
know all about that is a Hall of Fame
boxing analyst for Showtime television
author stage performer artist
Renaissance man good friend al Bernstein
oh yeah good to rebirth you as well I
give you the floor sir and what we saw
on Saturday night what did we see
performance by Tyson cheering and the
reason it was occurring is the way he
went about it you know in the first
fight which I was privileged to announce
the first pay-per-view where they fought
okay Tyson Fury did what he does he's an
exceptional boxer good defensive fighter
has a long jab and he boxed against the
slugger beyond to Wilders survived two
doctors one astonishingly the second
knockdown got up from the most amazing
thing I've seen in 40 years of
announcing boxing and yet for this fight
he pressed forward from the moment the
fight started and told us he was gonna
do that dance I certainly didn't think I
thought that was just him using
gamesmanship press forward useless you
have to walk his way in to walk down the
after wilder and and bullion which was
bet with to me was the extraordinary
part and I mean we were singing hymn
singing and dancing and just like like
he was getting ready for a stroll
through the park not a not a prize fight
in front of the entire universe ow
I mean that was amazing to witness that
for about five years I did boxing for
Channel five which is an over-the-air
network in the UK and I did a number of
Tyson Fury fights su is coming up and
you get to know somebody at that level a
little better because there's not all
the trappings around them and you didn't
have unfettered you know being available
to be with him and so
result I got to know him a little bit
and he is an extraordinary individual he
he has his belief here he has a quirky
life we can say that and so when you
look I was gonna make an analogy
remember how relaxed and easygoing
Evander Holyfield was before I think it
was before the the Tyson fight we saw
him singing and it's way in I mean in a
way it was like that well I mean you're
the perfect person to ask this question
since you've seen all these fights and
you are in the International Boxing Hall
of Fame for that have you ever seen
anybody licked the blood off the nape of
the neck of an individual whose ear he
might have punk yeah Corki was an
understatement of that I don't even know
how to describe the idea as been doing
that but that is it was strength well
that's the thing about boxing especially
heavyweight boxing whether it's somebody
coming in on a a jet pack crashing next
to the ring or any number of other
bizarre things that have happened the
one thing you can counter is that it
with Heavyweight Championship prize
fighting something strange is going to
happen Oh remember that time somebody
put out somebody's ear yes yeah I know I
mean all the fields the one who had his
ear bitten and Tyson's the one who did
that and now we've got a Tyson in a
first name just licking the the nape of
the neck of his opponent so how does one
beat fury now how does one we did see
Wilder come close just gotta get that
one punch in is that the way it works
here yeah has been down several times in
his career about five I think and and
you can put him down the problem is
keeping him down that is tricky he you
know but and remember he was closed he
was close to losing against Aravalli
knee in the previous fight to this when
he got cut badly now that can happen
any fighter obviously he's not
unbeatable obviously but he's very he's
a very difficult man to fight because
he's got his length he jabs well and
he's got a good chin and he's got good
defensive skills so he's very he's a
very awkward fighter and all of that
makes him tough to to fight now beyond
the wonder of course we wanted to get
the big right hand did he landed several
right answer early in the fight but then
really stopped throwing that punch for a
variety of reasons you know uh but you
need to be enticed intruder Danny Danon
was something something special
now Bernstein what the problem is him
because he's 69 because of his body too
because of the way he fights doing that
isn't always so easy al Bernstein here
on the Rich Eisen show is there a
comparison for Tyson Fury you got a good
cop you know one of the things that's
kind of annoyed me was on Twitter and
everywhere else is it people have been
obsessed with this idea of comparing he
waits to others and trying to figure out
where they place in history you know
this isn't it this isn't one of those
golden here it's a good area for
heavyweights not because people are
fighting each other and it's exciting
it's creating a lot of interest in a
sport that is having a renaissance to it
to degrade because there's a lot of
different things so that's good it's all
good I don't know what look he's a
handful for any heavyweight of the past
because of his height and his size and
the way he fights when he fits in
historically and who you could compare
him to I don't know if there's an AB
comparison because there's a man that a
heavyweight champions that are 6 foot 9
who fight like he fights Lennox Lewis uh
sure than the era of the big tall
heavyweight he's spectacular I think
Lennox was one of the great heavyweights
of all time but he's not he doesn't
fight exactly like Lennox Lewis so so
where do you stand on the subject of
louder's corner
not doing justice for their fighter by
throwing in the towel well they didn't
have a good night overall you know there
was a lot of you know Jimmy's and Markel
interprofessional guys I wouldn't
fashion them but they didn't have a good
night overall they did a great job of
dealing with his injuries
mark Breeland did that mark Berlin a
former welterweight champion a wonderful
man did that because he felt like his
fighter was in trouble
I would not criticize someone for doing
that clearly there was a disagreement
apparently in the corner about that
afterwards JD's said he would not have
done it but I think criticized the
corner for doing that Freelander Wilder
was in the corner in trouble and Mark
villain must have felt it at that
shelter with the injuries he had the
earrings are in tremendous bleeding from
the mouth and and and was not firing
back was not really punching back that
much mark knew himself that they'd seen
enough more Wilder said he wished he
could have been taken off on a shield
because that's what a warrior does but
maybe that's just the credits aligned to
compete and one of the interesting
things is you know Jenni's made the
point why he's got such a powerful
writing and he's come back for foreign
sides
yes he has he's been behind a number
fight but never beaten up and the
problem was in that fight he wasn't even
throwing the right hand at that point
and so the the major weapon that he
could have used that would have gotten
him back in this fight just wasn't being
used so it was problematic and Deontay
Wilder you know this is a tricky time
now does he accept the rematch clause or
healing has to do that within 30 days
the fight obviously can happen when he's
healthy but should he make that his next
fight he's 34 years of age can you
afford to fight a couple of fights
against somebody else and then get back
in against the perhaps the fury after
fury has gone off and done something
else big like fight Joshua or whatever
you know I don't know it's true
tricky decisions for them Shelly Finkel
suggested at the press conference that
they would accept the rematch
invoke the rematch clause will say well
let me ask you Albert's team what what
should he do in your estimation you laid
out some pros and cons you missed kind
of like made a list of what should be
and what should not be let's let's turn
the future here and start with that
question what do you think he should do
yeah it's a risky proposition if they do
that I I think if you if somebody said
to me you have to advise them and sure
they're desperate by the way to have me
as their advisor who isn't right but I
would probably say don't do it right
away
in 34 heavyweights mature later anyway
he's a power puncher that power is going
to be there no matter what I would say
have at least one fight in the in the
interim try and get him stable that's
where I would go and and if I was Tyson
Fury which I sense might be your next
question yes sir round I had a feeling I
am
you know I'd be I've ESPN that way wait
what did I say yes um the you know i
think i think that uh it tyson syria had
so many interesting paths available to
him one of those paths is a historical
one and i think they actually could make
this fight I actually believe they could
make the fight between him and Anthony
Joshua if they did that and that fight
was held in front of 90,000 people in
who and blue stating that would not only
be the biggest boxing event in British
history it would be a massive world
boxing event as well
and I it will be and it will be needless
to say in terms of being lucrative for
the fighters that and then some so then
what would prevent that from happening
well only fury deciding to go in another
direction I think or Joshua or not but
Eddie her and the promoters Joshua and
he has worked with Bobby I'm the
crank people that they've worked
together on fights a number of fights so
that is not the total impediment and and
I I don't know if there is anything that
would could group that would prevent it
if both fighters want that fight and
they might and God knows they can make
it make a pile of money but it's a risky
fight for in a way for both men
obviously because they're fighting
somebody that you know is potentially
can beat them which is what we want to
see in boxing and education right we
shouldn't be denigrating a fighter who's
one fight which Purse just happened to
do wild and everybody has written them
off already
that's what happens unfortunately but I
I think if I could be made yeah I mean
that's what makes the fights that's what
makes a fight the best al is that
everybody has a significant amount of
risk you know yeah absolutely I think
that both you know Joshua just is coming
off this win over Ruiz or establish
themselves I think it would be more on
the question of war the wilder wants to
do this right I think fear is found a
willingness to do these kinds of side to
end and theory will probably go in the
favorite in that side which is
interesting because that might not have
been the case a couple of years ago and
it will be interesting to see yeah I
gotta tell you I mean we had we had
Tyson fear al Bernstein couple more
minutes left with al Bernstein here on
the Rich Eisen show we had Tyson Fury
here in June we reposted a snippet of
that interview where he was talking
about his battle with mental illness and
and how are you yeah I mean it really
was just having him sitting in this
chair you know extending his legs which
was half of my desk you know look me in
the face and say that he came from a
family where communication and talking
about mental health problems was an
indication of weakness which made it
more difficult for him to deal with it
and he still deals with it every single
day I was just blown away by it and it
just makes him just honestly he's
straight out of like a Guy Ritchie movie
he's six foot nine he's singing American
Pie he's dancing before a fight he's
dominating in the fight
he's like an international superstar
right now
period he ivory all those things you
said you know it's owner ability to talk
about this by the way that injury was
great I do want that and she did with
them the the he has the vulnerability to
to and this is what for a little while
Tyson Fury got away from Eddie he tried
to come some supervillain and sound
rages and terrible things but I knew
that wasn't it's nice intruder was and
then he got back to being a more genuine
version of himself and and how about
this huh after a fight remember the
lyrics to two verses of American Pie
most people can't remember the verses to
American pies without having been beaten
and added for for you know what were six
rounds so that was pretty extraordinary
but you're right he is a fascinating
international figure and he's a brand
and it's gonna be very interesting of
course did the the key to keeping that
brand strong is winning in the rancher
doing that exactly in speaking of key
and keep your analyst hat on as a man
with his own lounge act his own singing
is all career
how was Tyson's pitch I thought he
sounded great don't you think to do that
acapella you know on the off-the-cuff in
front of all those people
I mean that was an extraordinary moment
let's be honest I mean when I don't
cinnamon takes the microwave of course
if you well know the major rule is you
hate to give up the mic once you've
given up the mic there's an inferior
dead man but he was smart enough to
understand that this was going to be a
truly special moment and and it became
something that will live on it's kind of
a folk legend yes after a fight but that
said al Bernstein versus Tyson Fury we
go to the cards you win that round ten
eight every time right ten seven what I
want to do is entice him to do a duet
with me
that's what I have to I have to get with
Tyson and say look it's time for us to
do it
it's no what would that be Furion
bernstein or bernstein and fury who gets
the top billing they're out now ok very
good now he's also 69 and his fist is
literally the size of my head so I think
that's a wise decision
you're the best I'll really appreciate
it always love our chats we'll chat soon
right back at you a Hall of Fame boxing
analyst and Hall of Fame human
individual al Bernstein for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on VR live or
download the Rich Eisen show app